college football is facing a variety of
challenges i still think that
that
it's not going to work and
the pac-12 on friday announced its plans
this year to play a 10-game
in conference schedule pac-12 players
though are revolting in a very
professional well-written statement that
was sent to the player's tribune now it
looks like they're getting help from
somebody and that's fine sure they need
help from somebody nobody's helping
these kids they are the ones who are the
pawns in this greater game of the
conferences trying to salvage as many of
the billions as they can uh you know hey
go ahead throw these kids onto campus
throw these kids into games let's not
have the kinds of standards that the nfl
has let's not be as obsessive compulsive
as we should be about limiting the
spread of the virus let's go forward
damn the torpedoes and i think it's
great that these players came together
they're concerned about racial injustice
they're concerned about covet 19 safety
and they they've made some very specific
demands or they're they're gonna sit out
the year and there will be no pac-12
football if enough of them stand down
now we don't know how many players are
involved we don't know how many schools
are involved it's supposedly a group of
players from multiple schools but if
they have enough sway over those schools
we could see no pac-12 football even
though the pac-12 plans to go forward
chris well i mean i applaud the players
of the pac-12 i mean they you know
they're they're kind of years ahead of
their time here just with you know the
fight of
you know equal pay or paying the players
more and compensating them more that
discussion now this i mean i get it you
know mike i mean i'll ask you have i i
really haven't heard of a
college plan yet what what is their plan
how are they going to go about testing
damn the torpedoes that's
the plan okay the plan is let's go okay
that's the plan let's go i just wanted
to make sure i wasn't missing something
because that's what i thought it was too
yeah you're right i've heard nothing
significant to go we're gonna do this
we're gonna take these steps and do that
and then do this and then you know the
players will feel safe and we'll make it
work it doesn't seem like any of that
conversations has happened and uh you
know good job pac-12 football players
seriously you know somebody like you
said has got to stick up for these kids
watch out for their their best interests
and i also like the yes the racial
injustice thing i mean come on you know
don't i don't even like
one thing that i has come clear to me
here is you know racial injustice
through this whole conversation and the
george floyd and all the other horrible
murders we've seen here all right the
the one thing that has come to the top
to me is we have a racism problem in our
country all's has done is exposed it
more to me so from that standpoint too
i'm proud of those players for standing
up to for such an important issue
well and it has here's how it relates to
college football
you've you've got a bunch of guys uh
mainly black young men who are
lured to come play college football with
this vague notion that they're on their
way to play in the nfl but the reality
is a very small percentage ever get a
check to play football they get an
education that in comparison to the
value of what they bring to the table
it's a joke and they're starting to
realize it's a joke and one of the
things the pac-12 players want is 50 of
the revenue of the gross revenue goes to
the players of the sports that generate
those revenues and look that's going to
hurt some of the non-revenue generating
sports but you know this this corrupt
system has been hiding in plain sight
for too long where
the players don't get nearly close to
the value of what they generate what
their sacrifices are with their
abilities dictate and the system just
keeps taking billions and billions and
billions and they'll spend on these
lavish facilities and the athletic
directors make a ton of money the
coaches make a ton of money and the
players don't get anything and and see
when the virus first hit
and we started projecting what was going
to happen i said if college football
isn't isn't careful here
they're going to expose yeah i remember
you said that it's been based on and
people are going to start to realize
look this this is all about making money
period it's not about
providing student athletes with a full
and complete college experience baloney
it's about making money preserving the
golden goose and doing whatever you have
to do to do it and the end result is
these schools that are obsessed with
playing college football and the money
that comes with it they're going to open
the campuses each campus is going to
become a super spreader locally and the
virus is going to rip through the
community and kill vulnerable people
and uh
hopefully hopefully people wake up and
realize that that's why we talked about
this friday chris peter king and i the
big ten
has told its members that they may not
play this year the big ten gets it the
big ten recognizes this may not be
sustainable and while these other
conferences sec acc pac-12 say damn the
torpedoes big 12 still hasn't said what
it's going to do the big ten is looking
at very seriously the possibility of not
playing at all because they recognize
right it may not be the right thing to
do for their kids their kids families or
the people who live in the communities
where these schools are yeah no i i mean
and that that's the the approach that
should be taken by these people of
leadership but mike i remember you said
that and you're right i mean just the
more time that's gone on it it seems
that it's slowly starting to expose
itself and it's all like you said just
you know full steam ahead we're playing
football we're playing football and we
haven't heard one ounce of a plan or how
they're gonna test or keep people safe
and oh you're going to have what the
kids there and not the the football
players at school but not the students
there i mean that will expose itself too
so we'll see where it goes i'm still in
the there's college football is not
going to happen until late fall winter
somewhere like that i just don't see it
going on
they're talking about playing ohio state
michigan in september october given the
possibility by the time they get to
november it will have all fallen apart
see that's the thing they're going to go
forward and it's it's it's the nfl's
let's see what happens attitude but with
less of a cohesive and comprehensive
plan
uh and it's just not going to work
especially in the areas where the virus
is still out of control and it's not
getting any better in a lot of those
areas because people still aren't taking
it seriously in the areas where it is
out of control